ici pierre desproges qui vous parle en
direct de monaco se déroule actuellement
le 225e festival annuel du film
pornographique sous le haut patronage ya
pas de patronage c'est trop porno le
film que j'ai vu pour vous hier soir au
familial ciné de monaco s'appelle oh oui
oh là là c'est bon encore oh la la
l'histoire bouleversante dans sa
simplicité éclaire sobrement le drame
humain de 11 sténodactylographe
magistralement interprété par les
majorettes de monaco et de 14
représentants de commerce vivent en
communauté dans un lit 240 dans le plus
complet dénuement un matin sonne à la
porte c'est le facteur plus précisément
ce sont les facteurs puisqu'ils sont
neufs magistralement interprété par les
compagnons de la chanson usant d'un
style elliptique qu'il méprise qu'ils
maîtrisent pardon à merveille depuis
glissons glissons j'ai rarement vu
quelque chose d'aussi osé l'auteur élude
volontairement une scène entière de
l'action la seule qui ne se passe pas
dans le lit de 140 voilà c'est un film
je vous répète qui est souvent très
dures quelquefois très mou mais jamais
vulgaire ici pierre desproges à vous les
studios